Wow, oh shit, sorry, give me a sec.
I already messed it up.
Sorry, I'm a mess right now.
Give me a sec, just pretend you didn't see that, guys.
Pretend you didn't see that.
Woah, let's start, let's start that all over.
Let's rerun that real quick, guys.
Let's rerun that.
Alright, sorry, rerun time.
Let's pretend none of that happened.
What a great start to Christmas.
Sorry, I'm like not okay right now.
I like have to put all of this together.
Pretend none of that happened.
Woah, rerun time.
Round three.
Hey.
Dragons, open the door!
It's Christmas!
Woah!
What do you mean?
You know what that means, dragons?
Come on, open the door!
Open the door!
You really gonna spend Christmas all alone there?
Come on, dragons.
Merry Christmas, everybody.
Stranger danger!
I look like the most trustworthy person here.
You wanna play some Marble Rivals?
Come on, dragons.
Come on, let's do a Latin party at my place with some Marble Rivals.
Please, there's a bird outside who wants to play Marble Rivals.
Come on, dragons.
Come on!
Good knock on the glass.
Let me in!
Let me in, dragon!
Please, I beg of you, open the door.
The fun for Toki's Marble Rivals.
More pausing in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, it'll be great.
Dragons, get in here!
Come here!
Oh my god, thank you.
Wait, let me in, sorry.
I realized I forgot all my stuff.
Okay, just pretend that the door was already closed.
And then I'll be more immersive.
And be like, wow!
I really appreciate it!
Thanks!
Sorry, I opened the door myself just then.
But like, don't worry.
I was polite enough to let you close the door.
And reopen the door for me.
There's some weak dragons there that opened the door before.
Yeah, I kicked off the door before you could do anything.
But I was polite enough to let you close the door.
And then, you know, let you open the door yourself.
Because it was your choice.
So do not worry.
Oh my god, Merry Christmas everybody!
I actually had like a whole other thing that I really wanted to set up.
I was setting up everything.
And I realized I forgot the one most crucial thing.
For the entire setup.
Which was you guys looking through the eye hole.
And then seeing like this eye hole vision.
Because I got inspired by this VTuber named Shindigs.
I think that's their name.
And they were doing like that shindags.
And they were doing this like Christmas caroling.
And I asked them how they did the door.
The eye door effect on their stream.
And then I was like.
Oh my god, I'm gonna do it.
And I did all of this and I forgot to do that.
Because they gave me a tutorial on how to do it.
And then, well they didn't give me a tutorial.
They were like, I'll write you a tutorial in two days.
But I messaged them this morning.
And then they were like.
So they were like, I'll give you a tutorial in two days.
But here are the plugins.
So I was gonna figure it out today.
And then I was like, I set up all of this.
And then I realized.
That was the one thing I forgot to set up.
Alright, immersion broken.
Sorry, back to the roleplay.
Merry Christmas, Dragoons.
What I just said was nothing.
Ignore everything I just said in the beginning.
Dragoons.
This is all real.
Ignore everything.
Do not wake up.
It's not a dream.
Get back in here.
Merry Christmas, everybody.
Merry Christmas.
Hello.
Hello, fellow stranger.
Hello, fellow Dragoons.
I'm here to give you some Christmas cheer.
I am a local caroler going door by door to give you some local Christmas cheer.
So I'm very excited to be, I'm just a poor old caroler trying to make sure everybody has a very merry Christmas.
I'm not here I'm not here to like convert you to any churches or like make you buy anything or anything.
I just want to spread some Christmas cheer and sing you some archives.
Sorry, it was reflex when I said unarchived.
Some Christmas holiday songs that will be staying on my channel for the rest of its life.
Channel?
What do you mean by channel?
We're at your door, at your house.
Sorry, sorry, that was just a slip of tongue.
I didn't take my meds today.
There's no, I'm just a humble Christmas caroler here to sing you some Christmas songs.
Are we on camera?
No, no, no.
No, of course not.
You're not on camera.
I'm just here to sing you some Christmas songs so you can have a good holiday, sir.
That's really, please don't close the door, please.
This is all I have.
No, please, dragons.
Please.
JK, don't go, please.
That was called the bad ending.
What do you mean good ending?
You waited an hour just for a god damn 10 minute stream?
You really wanted to wait an hour just for a 10 minute stream?
Really, dragon?
Good ending.
Now she's free to do Marvel Rivals.
Oh my god.
Alright, so, my very first song that I would like to sing to you guys is because I am wearing the appropriate outfit for it.
I don't know which one is the right one because, oh, this is the Alright, let's see this one.
Alright, guys.
Because I'm wearing the appropriate outfit.
Alright, I don't know Woah!
Wait, give me a sec.
Sorry, my the boombox I brought in is a little finicky right now.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me add some Let me put on my reverb my, uh, my mobile reverb that I have here.
As a Christmas caroler, we all carry natural reverb and a boombox with me.
Wait, boom what boombox?
Okay, don't make me My boombox is at my feet.
You don't see it, guys.
You don't see the boombox right now because it's literally at my feet.
Like, you just gotta look down.
Chat, you just gotta look down if you wanna see my boombox.
Alright, give me a sec.
I'm gonna, like, configure my boombox to make sure it's playing the appropriate song.
This is all free!
Okay, this is free entertainment, Mr. Dragoon.
I'm literally going door by door trying to spread some Christmas cheer.
And you're gonna get all cocky with me right now.
The immersion is dying!
I literally I literally, oh my god do I need to bring my boombox?
Do you guys have to see it?
Alright.
Here's my goddamn boombox.
Are you happy?
Is your immersion okay now?
There you go.
You see the boombox in the back right here.
Alright, there we go.
It's a tiny portable boombox, okay guys?
It's a goddamn portable boombox.
I don't know what you want from me.
I'm literally, I'm literally dead.
Immersion restored.
Alright.
Alright, wait a minute.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
This is, this is my Rudolf, oh wait, I wasn't supposed to tell you what the song is, but
Alright, sorry.
Sorry, alright, this time for it's not, it's not that.
Alright, here we go.
I'm ready.
I don't know what, let me know if the instrumental's okay.
Alright, here we go.
You're Dasher and Dancer and Prancer and Vixen Comet and Cupid and Donner and Blitzen But do you rec... I don't remember this part.
Sorry, I'm a great Christmas carer.
The most famous reindeer of all Rudolf the red-nosed reindeer had a very shiny nose.
Who knows about the intro?
And if you ever saw it, you would even say it glows All of the other reindeers used to laugh and call him names They never let poor old Rudolf join in any reindeer games.
God, I wanna eat them.
Then one foggy Christmas Eve, Santa came to say Rudolf with your nose so bright won't you guide my sleigh tonight?
Then how the reindeers loved him cause he feezed now, as they shouted out with dearly Goddamn cloud chasers.
Rudolf the red-nosed reindeer you'll go down in history Goddamn fucking leashes
All I'm saying is those reindeers are like fake-ass friends.
Like, what the fuck?
He's become famous, and then like um, and then now they wanna be his friends?
And the reindeers are like The guy in front of me is like, please, I'm I thought you were seeing Christmas carols, why are we having a conversation?
I was like, okay, but like, think of it this way mister, like, if you think about it, like, isn't Santa just a toxic piece of shit who like um, basically used used him for his bright, if he didn't have his bright nose he would've been discarded and went to the butchers,
if you think about it cause he had no other use and I mean like I think about it, mister Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer had a very shiny nose and if you ever saw it you would even say it glows all of the other reindeers used to laugh and call him names they never let poor Rudolph join in any reindeer games then one foggy Christmas eve,
Santa came to say Rudolph with your nose so bright won't you guide my sleigh tonight then how the reindeer loved him as they shouted out with glee Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer you'll go down in history yeah yeah did you enjoy the Christmas carol sir you know did you enjoy hahahaha hahahaha hahahaha did you like the Christmas carol sir well it's not free hahahaha If you would like...
All right, that'll be... that'll be $5.
Thank you for...
That'll be...
Because you're a great singer, I'd like to donate $100 to the Church of Marvelous Rivals.
Totally not a call, right?
$100!
Thank you for the... thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Shopkeeper, thank you for the... all right.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it, guys, for... for... for the...
Guys, busking is a hard job, okay?
Like, here you go, guys.
Here.
This is... sir, that'll be, like, um...
Um, $5 per song.
Uh, the first one is free, as you all know, so thank you so much.
Uh, so thank you so much for... for your contribution to me.
I hate this expression.
I hate it.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, thank you.
Busking is very hard.
Oh my god, it's a tough world out there.
Uh, yeah, I put some of my money in there myself, um, to make it seem like a lot of people were tipping me.
So you know how, like, people would... they won't make an empty jar?
The busker would, like, put, like, a little bit of cash in there so people would think, like, there's actual, um...
Like, people are actually tipping and be like, wow, he's... they're doing a really good service.
And...
That... this is how... yeah, this is how the mafia works, exactly.
Uh, but yes, thank you.
Thank you so much, sir.
Thank you so much.
All right, so my next song... my... my next song will be a classic, um, for all of you guys.
It'll be a... it'll be a classic for...
All right, all right, thank you.
Ahem, ahem.
All right, here we go.
Jingle bells, jingle bells, jingle all the... okay, wait, give me a sec, my boombox fucked up.
Sorry, let me get a better jingle bells.
Ooh, the chill... sorry, this was... I didn't like that.
I didn't like that one.
Sorry.
There we go.
Ooh, this one sounds nicer.
Sorry, my boombox was messing up.
Jingle bells, jingle bells, jingle all the way.
Oh, what fun it is to ride in a one-horse open sleigh.
Yeah!
Jingle bells, jingle bells, jingle all the way.
Oh, what fun it is to ride in a one-horse open sleigh.
Dashing through the snow in a one-horse open sleigh.
Over the fields we go, laughing all the way.
Ha-ha!
Bells on bobtails ring, making spirits bright.
What fun it is to ride and sing a sleighing song tonight.
Oh, jingle bells, jingle bells, jingle all the way.
Oh, what fun it is to ride in a one-horse open sleigh.
Whoa!
Jingle bells, jingle bells, jingle all the way.
Oh, what fun it is to ride in a one-horse open sleigh.
Yeah!
Woo!
A day or two ago...
You didn't think there'd be a second chorus, right?
And soon Miss Fanny Bright was seated at my side.
Who the fuck is she?
The horse was lean and lank, Miss Fortune seen his lot.
He slipped upon a drifting bank and then we got upset.
Did she die?
Jingle bells, jingle bells, jingle all the way.
Oh, what fun it is to ride in a one-horse open sleigh.
Woo!
Jingle bells, jingle bells, jingle all the way.
Sorry, I had to, like, breathe.
One-horse open sleigh.
Look, I'm just a caroler.
Alright, thank you.
That is what five dollars of singing gets you.
Whoa!
Sorry, my boombox is messing up right now.
Alright, that's what five dollars of singing gets you.
Pay for the carol.
Guys, that's when you know it's not pre-recorded.
Guys, caroling, sir.
That's when you know it's not pre-recorded, sir.
Me, I'm doing it all live.
With just me and my boombox.
Okay?
Me and my boombox back there.
Wham!
Last Christmas, I'd cry.
Okay, alright.
Never sang that before.
Let's see how hard that is.
Uh, Kaiser, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
We're just... Oh my god, there's a Taylor Swift version?
There's an Ariana...
Sorry, my boombox has a lot of songs in there.
It's like an Apple boombox.
So like, I get access...
I have Spotify on my boombox right now.
So...
Alright, let's see what does this sound like.
Oh man.
What the... Oh my god.
Last Christmas...
Sorry, I like skimmed through.
Wait, let's get a Taylor Swift version.
On my Spotify boombox.
Like, okay.
Okay, do you want to be more immersive?
Alright, give me a sec so we know...
We know exactly that it is...
Oh my god, it's like country.
Okay.
That it is a Spotify...
Um, sir, this is a Spotify boombox.
Um...
It...
It costs...
I actually googled Spotify boombox on my phone, by the way.
Like, I have my phone with me while I'm Christmas caroling.
And everything...
No!
Oh my god, there's an Ariana Grande on my Spotify boom...
Okay, look.
Sir, do you really want to see the license on my boombox?
It is 100% from...
Um...
From Spotify.
I'll show you right now.
Uh, give me a sec.
I did not just print this out on my...
Print this out and attached it onto my boombox.
Like, I would never do something that stupid.
Um...
Sir, this is my Spotify boombox.
Alright?
Like, it costs a lot of money.
Okay?
So, like, I need you to know that, um...
I am able to access a lot of my favorite songs on my Spotify boombox.
So we can do my Christmas caroling.
Okay?
So please, don't think it's not fake.
It's all real.
I am actually outside your door right now.
Trying to make ends meet here.
There you go.
Now you see the Spotify logo as well.
So...
Um, look.
It's Christmas.
I'm trying to make ends meet.
I have a lot of children to feed.
Um, I have...
I have a family and everything.
So please, I'm trying my best here.
I'm...
I'm trying...
Please play the WAM version, man.
Noxbob, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Where's...
That's the...
What does the WAM version sound like?
Alright, Spotify boombox.
Show me what it sounds like.
Okay.
What is this?
As made famous by WAM.
Wait, there's like a guy and a girl singing this.
Alright, I'm having them sing with me.
Also, I never...
Oh, I can bring up the instrument a little bit.
Okay, don't worry.
I'll bring it up.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart.
But the very next day, you gave it away.
This year, you saved me from tears.
I'll give it to someone special.
Wait, wait.
Stop.
Sorry.
I have an idea.
Sorry, sir.
Give me a sec.
I got...
Sorry, let me bring one of my kids over.
Kids!
Come in here, kids!
Whoa!
Hey, sorry.
Sorry, I got one of my children to be a backup dancer.
Sorry.
Give me a sec.
There we go.
Alright, kid.
We're gonna...
We need you to do a backup dancing.
Alright, there we go.
Sorry.
Sorry, now let's double.
That's the...
Alright, there we go.
Alright, take two.
Alright.
Alright, little dokey.
You're gonna work hard for your money tonight.
Alright.
You wouldn't...
Come on, dude.
I brought a child with me, too.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart.
But the very next day, you gave it away.
This year, to save me from tears, I'll give it to someone special.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart.
But the very next day, you gave it away.
This year, to save me from tears, I'll give it to someone special.
Did my child do great?
Come on.
She's amazing.
She harmonized with me, sir.
I brought her out.
It's like negative 10 degrees.
I bring her out to do Christmas caroling for me.
We got a whole family to feed here.
Once bitten and twice shy.
I keep my distance as soon as you catch my eye.
Tell me, baby, do you recognize me?
Well, it's been a year.
It doesn't surprise me.
Merry Christmas.
Last Christmas, I wrapped it up and sent it.
With a note saying, I love you, I meant it.
Now I know what a fool I've been.
But if you kissed me now, I know you'd fool me again.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart.
But the very next day, you gave it away.
This year, to save me from tears, I'll give it to someone special.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart.
But the very next day, you gave it away.
This year, to save me from tears, I'll give it to someone special.
A crowded room, friends with tired eyes.
I'm hiding from you and your soul of ice.
My God, I thought you were someone to rely on.
Me, I guess I was a shoulder to cry on.
Face of a lover, with a fire in his heart.
A man undercover, but you tore me apart.
That's fucked up, bro.
Now I've found a real love, you'll never fool me again.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart.
But the very next day, you gave it away.
This year, to save me from tears, I'll give it to someone special.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart.
But the very next day, you gave it away.
This year, to save me from tears, I'll give it to someone special.
Oh, that's a sad song.
That's a really sad song.
I made my child sing it.
I'm gonna put my whole heart into it.
Hey, little jokey, what do you have to say about that, little jokey, after a good song?
After a nice song that we sang together.
Oh my god, what is this?
You have your own tiny little tip jar?
Please, sir.
This will go towards my Christmas presents today.
Leave the child alone.
Wow, little jokey.
I'm following your old man's footsteps.
I'm so proud of you.
I'm so proud of you, little jokey.
Solid Snake, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Isn't this extortion and bringing your child?
Look, you don't tell me how I parent my child.
Thank you for the super chat, Solid Snake.
Happy Christmas, dear keeper and child keeper.
You don't tell me how I parent my little jokey.
I'm the parent here.
And we're trying to bring some Christmas cheer.
Santino, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
For Dokia Jr. Max Sleepy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you all.
Thank you for the tip.
Thank you for the tip for little jokey.
Thank you, thank you.
This is for the child only.
Thank you for the little tip.
Thank you, thank you.
Tips for little jokey.
Alright, little jokey.
It's time to go, little jokey.
Go back in the car with the other jokeys.
Okay.
Alright.
Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
I hope you've been enjoying the Christmas carols.
It has been a lot of work.
Oh my god.
You wouldn't know how many houses I've been to tonight.
Surprisingly one, which is yours.
And honestly, I know there's a lot of houses.
But I saw your Lamborghini out in the backyard.
And I knew this was the perfect house to bring in some Christmas cheer.
Oh my god, sir.
Is that a new Rolex watch you have there?
Alright, so I also brought my dog.
So, give me a sec while I bring him over.
Give me a sec.
Don't worry.
I brought my dog too.
But like, he's into this.
Okay, so don't worry.
Give me a sec while I bring him over.
No.
Excuse me, what do you mean ain't no way?
Dogs want Christmas cheer too.
Like, what's wrong with that?
Sometimes my pet wants to spend Christmas with me as well.
What's wrong with that, sir?
Are you judging my fucking dog now?
Wow, on Christmas?
Oh my god, no wonder you needed more Christmas cheer.
Oh wait, sorry.
Sorry for the lack of immersion there.
Sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
You just forgot to take your meds, sir.
There's no bubbles or anything.
You just forgot to take your meds there.
No, there's nothing weird in the background.
You just forgot to take your meds, sir.
That's really it.
There's nothing weird going on in the background.
Do not worry.
Alright, sir.
I'm coming back.
I brought my dog here.
Don't worry.
Alright.
Here we go.
Wait, that's not my... that's not it.
This one.
Alright.
Wait, that's not it.
Where am I?
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Ah, hey there.
I'm back.
I brought my dog too.
I think I was like...
Here, this was where I was sitting.
Alright, there you go.
Yeah.
Oh, see?
Me, Doki Amber Doge.
We call him Dad for short.
Alright.
I brought him here to also sing us some Christmas carols.
He's also a separate fee if you don't know.
So, yeah.
It's a double, you know, double the people, double the tip.
He also has his own little...
Oh, am I taller than usual?
My bad.
Am I?
I don't even remember where I was standing, to be fair.
Like, you know, I like costume changes and everything.
It's a lot of work.
But, don't worry.
Don't worry.
We also have a...
Doki Amber Doge also has a special song to sing for you.
Alright.
What the fuck is this?
Jordan Smith version?
There's a gym?
Oh, wait.
Oh, my gosh.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
That's right.
He has a little antler.
You know, maybe...
Maybe because he has a little antler, I should, like...
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, give me a sec.
Because he has a little antler, I feel like...
Alright, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
Sorry.
Give me a...
Give me, like, a little bit.
Whoa.
Sorry.
You just forgot to take your meds.
That's really it.
There's nothing weird going on.
You just forgot to take your meds.
Alright.
There we go.
Now, let me stand further away so you can see this costume.
So, you see the little costume he has on.
Alright, there we go.
Alright, I just stood a little further...
Sorry, I have to go back.
And then...
Because you have a lot of steps on your porch.
You know.
You literally live on the hill.
So, I don't know why.
I think...
I don't know.
It feels like you don't want people, like, caroling at your doorstep.
Because you live on a hill.
Excluded from the rest of the town.
Looking down at the rest of the town.
So, I have to go down.
I have to, like, go down a couple of steps.
And that's why I, like, you know, went down a little.
So, now I'm, like, further away.
So, you can see my Jokey Amber, like, dad's little costume over here.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Sorry.
Give me a sec.
Let me reset my boombox.
Alright, here we go.
How do I get past security?
Don't...
We don't mention that.
I have, like, several children.
You're a mean one.
Mr. Grinch.
But you're very rich.
You really are a heel.
You're as cuddly as a cactus.
You're as charming as an eel, Mr. Grinch.
You're a bad banana with a greasy black peel.
Sir, don't worry.
I'm not talking about you.
Don't worry.
It's not a song about you, sir.
You're a monster.
Yeah, that's right.
That's you, Mr. Grinch.
I'm not talking about you, by the way.
Your heart's an empty hole.
Your brain is full of spiders.
You've got garlic in your soul, Mr. Grinch.
I wouldn't touch you with a 39 and a half foot pole.
You're a foul one, Mr. Dragon.
You have termites in your smile.
You have all the tender sweetness of a seasick crocodile, Mr. Dragon.
Given the choice between the two of you, I'd take the seasick crocodile.
Oh, sorry.
That was a slip of tongue.
I didn't mean you guys.
Sorry, sir.
That was a slip of tongue, sir.
I was just thinking about how much you're not all of that.
You're a rider, Mr. Grinch.
You're the king of sinful thoughts.
Your heart's a dead tomato splat with moldy purple spots, Dragon.
You're a three-decker sour-crying toastless sandwich with arsenic sauce.
Aw, man.
Did I say dragon once again?
Aw, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
It's just another slip of tongue.
You nauseate me, Mr. Grinch.
With a nausea supernause.
You're a crooked jerky jockey and you drive a crooked horse, Mr. Grinch.
Your soul is an appalling dump heap overflowing with the most disgraceful assortment of rush-bush imaginable mangled up and tangled up nuts.
You're a foul one, Mr. Grinch.
You're a nasty waxy skunk.
Your port is full of unwashed socks, your soul is full of gunk, Mr. Grinch.
The three words that best describe you are as follows, and I quote...
Sink, sank, sunk.
Sorry, this is like the second time I've sang this song, and then I forgot what the lyrics were at the end, so...
So I was like, whoa, that's pretty fucked up.
Twice is a coincidence, three times a problem.
Sorry, sorry, did I slip up again?
And I'm just thinking about how much... I was just thinking about you guys so much that it just...
It just like, slipped my mind, it just self-inserted itself into the song.
It could've been any song, Dragoons, it really could've been.
It was just, unfortunately, it was that song that like, on my head, my head was just like, Dragoons, Dragoons!
And then like, you know, because of that, like...
It just, it just like, slipped my mind, and then you got into the song.
It's just, unfortunately, I did not mean that, sir.
I did not mean that, sir, of course.
DK, thank you for the superchat, thank you, thank you.
You're hilarious, my favorite song so far.
Thank you for the superchat.
Aw, man, really, I mean, on Christmas, aw, don't cry, guys!
On Christmas?
Come on!
You got inserted into the song, Dragoons!
Is that what you want?
You got a shout-out!
Even dad sang along, he even shouted you out, guys!
Every song is my favorite, sir.
Come on, don't close the door!
Come on!
He even...
Don't close the door!
He even has his own little tip jar!
Are you really?
Look at that!
Look at that, it's his own little tip jar!
You're really gonna not let him have any doggy treats tonight?
Come on!
Um, the amount of extortion for this kill makes me wonder if the ring doorbell was worth it.
WDN, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
What did we get out of so many songs?
Alright, alright, let me put my...
Let me put my dog back in the trunk real quick.
Alright, don't close the door though!
Guys, don't close the door.
I'll be back, just watch.
Leave the door open so you can watch me put the dog back in the trunk.
Don't worry, I'll be back.
I'll be back, don't worry.
You guys want more immersion?
Don't worry guys, I'm gonna...
Okay, I'm gonna give you guys so much immersion.
Don't worry.
I'm going down.
Alright, yeah.
Don't worry, I'll be back.
There's so many stairs.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you live so far up, sir.
You live so far up.
Oh my god, alright.
Okay, alright.
Dad, you gotta...
Alright, give me a sec.
I'm gonna put him...
I'm putting him in the trunk right now.
Give me a sec.
Alright, got it.
Get to the car.
There's the car.
Alright, here we go.
Where's my keys?
Alright, there you go.
Alright, get in there.
That's right.
Yeah.
Alright, here, let me get you some stuff real quick.
Okay.
Bye, little dokey.
You wanted a drink?
Don't worry, I got you some drinks.
Stop opening the car door!
Everything's fine.
I'm coming back up now.
I'm coming back up.
You have so many stairs.
Oh my god.
So many goddamn stairs here.
I'm walking back up.
Don't worry, I'm getting there.
Alright, there you go.
Woah, sorry.
Your house moved a little bit.
That was freaky as hell.
But I'm coming back.
Hello.
I'm back.
I hope that was very immersive.
So you felt like...
You know, you were...
So it felt like, you know, you were actually there.
I hope that was very immersive for you.
As it was for me.
Because I definitely went down the staircase and everything.
So, yeah.
He's in the trunk now.
And I'm here to sing more Christmas carols.
I'm here for to give you some more holiday cheer.
Here to take this money and buy yourself a domestic inventive gift bag.
Honestly, you're only away from this kidnapper.
Thank you for...
Woah, sorry!
Thank you for the super chat.
Oh my god, sorry.
I had to read Sorry, I had to read this message on my phone.
So, it like...
If I'm going back and forth, it's cause like...
I had to look at something real quick.
But everything's okay now.
Everything should be okay.
Alright, here we go.
Next Christmas carol that I have for you.
Oh my god, give me a sec.
Sorry, I'm moving all over the place.
I'm just so happy to be here.
Sorry, I'm so happy to be here, so I'm moving all over the place right now.
Alright, yeah.
It's just very slippery.
Have you ever thought about salting your porch?
It's very slippery right here.
Alright.
This is a classic that...
I love to sing.
I'm trying to remember the song name.
I don't know...
I don't know if you know this, but like...
I'm doing all of this live.
I didn't really come in here with a set list.
I would just be like...
Oh man, this is what I feel like singing right now.
So like...
Give me a sec.
Okay, I need to pull out my phone.
Real quick.
To find this thing that I'm trying to find.
Yes!
I'm winging it!
Each house I visit gets a unique experience.
A unique experience tailored towards the specific house I'm singing to.
So you don't understand, sir.
Merry Christmas!
Don't keep it from a fellow YouTuber to another.
God bless you!
Thank you for your very first tip!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
See, this dragon gets it.
Look, look, look.
You are the first house I visited.
Each house I go to, I will improve.
Okay, sir?
So like...
Why are you... This is a free experience!
Well, not really.
But...
Um...
I mean...
This is a free experience!
Why are you complaining?
Okay, um...
Alright, here.
Um...
Okay.
What was the song called?
Oh my gosh, sorry.
I'm like, okay.
I figured it out.
Alright, Spotify Boombox.
Grab me the song.
There you go.
Thank you, Spotify Boombox.
This is a classic.
Alright.
I'll stop the instruments.
It's okay.
I don't know if it's too loud or not.
I'm Mr. White Christmas.
I'm Mrs. Snow.
I'm Mrs. Icicle.
I'm Mrs. Ten Below.
Friends call me Snow Mizer.
Whatever I touch turns to snow in my clutch.
I'm too much.
That's right!
That's me!
Wow!
Friends call me Snow Mizer.
Whatever I touch turns to snow in my clutch.
Whoa!
Too much.
I never want to know a day that's over 40 degrees.
I'd rather have it 20, 30, and 5 and let it freeze!
He's Mr. White Christmas.
He's Mrs. Snow.
That's right!
I'm Mrs. Icicle.
I'm Mrs. Ten Below.
Friends call me Snow Mizer.
Whatever I touch turns to snow in my clutch.
Too much.
Wow!
That's honestly one of my favorite songs, sir.
So, like, I hope you appreciate this experience because this is honestly one of my favorite Christmas songs in general.
So, like, I'm very happy that I was able to sing this for you again.
Honestly, this is actually my go- I don't know!
It's honestly one of my top 10 Christmas songs- Top 5!
Top 5 Christmas songs because it's such- I feel like it fits my personality a lot so I'm really happy to be able to sing that.
Alright!
Anyway.
Whatever- Okay, what other Christmas songs do I know for you guys?
Give me a sec.
I'm thinking.
I'm just like, there's so many Christmas songs in the world.
Oh, wait!
I know.
I know exactly.
Alright.
Oh, yeah.
Alright, so I brought a little prop for this one.
I brought a little prop for us today for this particular song because I felt like, you know, the visuals for it would really work really well for it.
So, give me a sec.
Let me grab this prop.
Don't worry!
I already brought- I don't have to go downstairs to the trunk again to grab this particular prop.
So, do not worry.
Um...
Here it is.
I hope it's okay if I put it in your house, though.
I hope that's alright.
Alright, so...
There's- There he is.
Alright.
There's a two-minute version on my boombox?
Alright, let's do this.
Yeah!
No way.
Frosty the snowman was a jolly, happy soul with a corncob pipe and a button nose and his eyes made out of coal.
Frosty the snowman made the children laugh and play and were they surprised when before their eyes he came to life that day.
There must have been some magic in that old silk hat they found for when they placed it on his head he began to dance around.
Oh!
Frosty the snowman was as live as he could be and the children say he could laugh and play the same as you and me.
Frosty the snowman knew the sun was hot that day so he said, let's run and we'll have some fun before I melt away.
So down to the village with a broomstick in his hand running here and there all around the square saying, catch me if you can.
He led them down the streets of town right to the traffic stop and he only paused a moment when they heard him holler, stop!
Oh!
Frosty the snowman had to hurry on his way but he waved goodbye saying, don't you cry, I'll be back again someday.
Thumpity, thump, thump, thumpity, thump, thump, look at Frosty go.
Thumpity, thump, thump, thumpity, thump, thump, over the hills of snow.
Yay!
Woo!
He will be remembered.
Yay!
Magic hat and carrot and coal and then he'll come back to life Might not be the same guy again, but like, you know, I might have some trauma in those eyes, but he'll be back Just wait next year My house
All right, all right sir because I feel awfully generous today Why don't we do some live Christmas carol song request sir?
What do you what do you have in that noggin of yours that you want me to sing tonight?
Well, what you just gotta wait next year sir, you just you just gotta wait oh my god, I am NOT doing Santa, baby I'm I'm not doing Santa, baby guys All right, you know who would love to do Santa baby, all right, let me let me go grab him let me Alright,
give me let me go grab him real quick guys.
Let me Me all right.
Let me go down the goddamn stairs again.
Just for you.
I know somebody who would love to sing Santa baby.
That's really what you want That's oh wait, oh my gosh, what am I doing?
Oh my god.
He's already here.
Anyway.
All right Let me go back up the stairs guys.
I'm here.
Sorry.
You got a lot of stairs.
I need to go back up.
I Never asked is my boombox so too loud or is it a just right?
I never realized Is my boombox?
Okay, or is it or is it not?
Okay.
I should have asked you guys that before
All right, let's get to know all right Whoop, we're sorry.
I pulled my got my nose Accidentally got my nose.
Sorry about that.
Oh got my hat
Do I not is there anything I can okay here you all right At the zoom in real quick For this, oh my god, I got my hat again.
Oh My god, please why is my hat sorry my hat my hat is very sensitive
My hat is a very sensitive hat There you go, all right, there you go I've been zoom in a really hard with it.
I have the I decided to go up to your face.
Oh my god No, this looks oh my god.
Just look realize what this looks like.
Give me a second Is you mean even more so it doesn't look like that.
I
Don't don't worry about it Don't fucking worry about it.
I Don't worry about it Oh my god, why is it like this?
What is it?
I'm fucking I'm gonna take this off.
I'm good
There we go now that feels much more much better now, all right, there we go
Okay, all right, hey if you really want Santa baby you gotta look him in the eyes
You gotta look him in the eyes if you really want Santa baby
Oh my god, there's a Madonna version.
Oh my god, I'm gonna see and get the earth earth the kid version
All right, here we go All right, I'm gonna sing as if like I'm him but um
Santa baby, it's just under the tree for me Been an awful good boy Down the chimney tonight
Santa baby a 54 convertible too Light blue I'll wait up for you dear Santa baby hurry down the chimney tonight Woof woof Think of all the fun I missed you Ah, think of all the dragoons, having this.
Next year, I could be just as good.
If you check off my Christmas list.
Santa baby, I want a chicken and really that's not a lot.
Wow.
Been an angel all year.
Santa baby, so hurry down the chimney tonight.
Santa honey, one little thing I really need.
The deed.
To that bitch's house down the street.
God, I hate that poodle.
So hurry down the chimney tonight.
Santa cutie, fill my stocking with the doggie treats and checks.
Sign your X on the line, Santa cutie.
And hurry down the chimney tonight.
Bow wow, bro.
Come and trim my Christmas tree.
With some decorations bought at Tiffany's.
I really do believe in you.
Let's see if you believe in me.
Santa baby, forgot to mention one little thing.
A ring.
I don't mean on the phone, Santa baby.
So hurry down the chimney tonight.
Hurry down the chimney tonight.
Hurry down tonight.
Woof woof.
Wow, Dad!
That was amazing!
Amazing singing you got there!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sing the night, Santa went crazy.
I never even heard that song before.
Dad is just fine, guys.
Voice is just a little husky.
Get it?
Husky.
Hee hee.
I'mma head out.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What do you mean?
That was amazing!
Oh my God, he was such an amazing singer.
I can't believe... you don't even... you don't even... oh my God, I can't believe he's trying to sing.
He didn't sing really well today.
Guys, I'm trying... don't... are you going to hurt him?
Come on, guys.
Are you going to really hurt him like that?
He let his whole heart out in that song.
He was so passionate and everything.
Alright, let me zoom out real fast.
Alright, get down.
Get down.
Your solo is over.
Now it's back to doki hours.
Oh my gosh, my hat.
Don't worry, I can fix it.
Wait, what happened to my nose?
What?
Sorry, he like... he like freaking moved around so much that my nose fell off.
It's like right here.
Alright, there it is.
Yeah!
There we go.
We fixed it.
Everything can be fixed.
Sorry, I fixed it, guys.
Everything was fine.
I fixed it.
Alright.
Go back here and then...
Yay!
Alright, there we go.
Now I'm back in position.
Alright.
Alright!
Any other song requests for this festive night?
Merry Christmas, by the way.
Merry Christmas, everybody.
Alright, let's see.
No, okay.
I need Christmas suggestions, guys.
Any... any...
Any Christmas suggestions.
Do we even have Five Nights at Freddy's and Carrie fun?
Five Nights at Freddy's.
Oh my God, wait.
Okay, I don't know.
I don't know if I can sing this, though.
Cause like, I don't know.
I don't know.
Alright, here we go.
Hoot, hoot, hoot.
We're poor little souls who have lost all control And we'll force you to take that role We've been all alone Stuck in our little zone since 1987 Join us, be our friend Or just be stuck in the pen After all, you only got Five Nights at Freddy's Is this where you wanna be?
I just don't get it Why do you wanna stay Five Nights at Freddy's Is this where you wanna be?
I just don't get it Why do you wanna stay Five Nights at Freddy's
Wow!
Hoot, hoot, hoot.
Five Nights at Tootie's.
Oh my God.
We're really quite surprised We get to see you another night You should have looked for another job You should have sex, it's place goodbye It's like there's so much more Maybe you've been in this place before We remember a face like yours You seem acquainted with those doors Please let us get in,
don't walk us away We're not like what you're thinking We're poor little souls who have lost all control And we're forced here to take that role We've been on our own, also in our little zone Since 1987 Join us, be a friend, or just be stuck in a vent After all,
you only got five nights at Freddy's Is this where you wanna be?
I just don't get it Why do you wanna stay five nights at Freddy's?
Is this where you wanna be?
Oh my god, oh my god, I love this song
Wait, is there?
Wait, okay Okay, now that we're in that territory now Now we're not at the traditional Christmas songs now Do you think?
No!
I was gonna see if they have this particular song That one is saying, you know what?
Since we're in this area now It's time to sing Let's see Oh wait, can I do this one?
But I might solo this myself I don't know actually Wait, can I do it?
Okay I'll never sang this one before So like, oh wait, what the fuck is this one?
I'm trying to see if like, okay I'm gonna see if there's one that I can solo I can solo myself
Alright, let's see Alright,
this one I love this song so much I'm gonna try and solo this I don't know if I could I'm gonna put the actual person singing it Because yeah, that's it Everything is awesome Everything is cool when you're part of the team Everything is awesome when we're living in a dream Everything is better when we stick together Side by side,
you and I, we're gonna win forever Let's party forever We're the same, I'm like you, you're like me We're all working in harmony Everything is awesome Everything is cool when you're part of the team Everything is awesome when we're living in a dream 3,
2, 1, go Have you heard the news?
Everyone's talking Life is good cause everything's awesome Lost my job, it's a new opportunity More free time for my awesome community I feel more awesome than an awesome possum Dip my body in chocolate frosting 3 years later, wash off the frosting Smell like a possum,
everything is awesome Striped in mud, I got new brand shoes It's awesome to win and awesome to lose Yeah!
Woo!
Everything is better when we stick together Side by side, you and I, we're gonna win forever Let's party forever We're the same, I'm like you, you're like me We're all working in harmony Everything is awesome Everything is cool when you're part of the team Everything is awesome when we're living our dream Blue skies,
bouncy streets We just named two awesome things Noble prize, a piece of string You know what's awesome?
Everything!
Dogs with fleas, allergies A book of Greek antiquities Brand new pants, very old vets Awesome items, all the best Trees, frogs, clogs, they're awesome!
Rocks, clocks, and socks, they're awesome!
Figs, and jigs, and twigs, that's awesome!
Everything you say or think or say is awesome!
Wow!
You guys know this is the first time I ever sang that song?
I just listened to it so much!
I love Lonely Island, I told you guys!
I also realized my floor was open in the entire time.
Well, I hope my neighbors don't complain.
Sorry, your neighbors don't complain.
Everything is awesome!
Everything is cool when you're part of the team Everything is awesome when we're living our dream Yeah!
Sorry, I love that song.
I realized I could finally sing it.
Oh my gosh, my chair like broke through.
My like, paper bag that was next to me.
I just want to sing it because it has a rap part.
I love the Lonely Island rap part there.
Alright, so I was singing like, oh my gosh, it's like, I love Lonely Island, but all their songs require another person to sing with me.
Like this one.
I'm going to sing this one.
I'm happy.
Bro, I love Mother Lover, but like I said, it all...
Aw, shit!
Get your towels ready, it's about to go down!
Everybody in a place, hit the fucking deck!
But stay on your motherfucking toes!
We're ready, let's go.
I'm on a boat, I'm on a boat Everybody look at me cause I'm sailing on a boat I'm on a boat I'm on a boat Take a good hard look at this motherfucking boat I'm on a boat, motherfucker, take a look at me Straight floating on a boat on the deep blue sea Busting five knots,
wind whipping out my coat You can't stop me, motherfucker, cause I'm on a boat Take a picture, chick, I'm on a boat, bitch We drinking Santana Champ cause it's so crisp I got my swim trunks and my flippy floppies I'm flipping burgers, you at Kinko's flipping copies I'm riding on a dolphin,
doing flips and shit The dolphin's splashing, getting everybody all wet But this ain't SeaWorld, this is real as it gets I'm on a boat, motherfucker, don't you ever forget I'm on a boat and it's going fast and I've got a nautical theme, Pachima Afghan I'm the king of the world on a boat like Leo If you're on the shore,
then you're sure not Mio Fuck off, this boat is real Fuck loud, I'm on a boat, motherfucker Fuck trees, I climb buoys, motherfucker I'm on the deck with my boys, motherfucker This boat engine make noise, motherfucker Hey, Molly, if you see me now I'm trying to ride on a starboard bow Gonna fly this boat to the moon somehow Like Kevin Garnett,
anything is possible Never thought I'd be on a boat It's a blue, blue, watery road Poseidon, look at me Never thought I'd see the day When a big boat coming my way Believe me when I say I fucked up, man I'm on a boat, I'm on a boat Everybody look at me cause I'm sailing on a boat I'm on a boat,
I'm on a boat Take a good hard look at the motherfucking boat
I really apologize, I just...
I just really love Lonely Island What can I say?
Merry Christmas, everybody Merry Christmas
Okay, but this one's also...
Okay, now I'm just shitposting Now it's not just Christmas carols I'm just... Sorry, sir Sorry, now we're just going through my favorite songs I hope that... It's like...
I'm basically giving you several encores now, sir Like, we start off with some humble Nice, Christmas-friendly, PG-friendly Christmas carols Now it's After Dark time Now we're at the After Dark Twitter messages here We're freestyling now
Alright, oh wait, what about this one?
Okay, I need a partner for this, but I can solo this I'll have someone else be Justin Timberlake Someone else can be Justin Timberlake for me Oh, we can't do that, okay Oh dang, what?
I forgot it's Mother's Day Other plans got in the way So disappointed This could have been avoided What the hell are we gonna do?
Cold
I know just what you mean My mom's been so sad and gray My dad can't satisfy her in the bedroom Ever since he passed away Hold up, you thinking what I'm thinking?
Blow up, what time is it, dog?
We both love our moms Women with grown women means I say we break him up, show him how much they really mean Cause I'm a mother lover, you're a mother lover We should fuck each other's mothers Fuck each other's moms I'm pushing that place that you came out as baby Ain't no doubt that shit is crazy Cause every Mother's Day means a Mother's Night If doing it is wrong,
I don't wanna be right I'm calling on you cause I can do it myself To me you're like a brother So be my mother lover I'm laying in the cup Waiting for your mom clutching on sleeping roses
They would be so surprised Can't wait to pork your mom Showed enough Straight up Give it to my d-d-d-d-doggy style This is a perfect plan for a perfect Mother's Day They have to rename this one all up under the covers, they Cause I'm a mother lover, you're a mother lover We should fuck each other's mothers,
fuck each other's moms I'm pushing that lady where you came out spinnin' baby Ain't no doubt that shit is crazy Breakdown It would be my honor to be your new stepfather To be your new stepfather And while you're in my mother, make me another brother And while I'm in your mother,
I'll never use the rope It's a Mother's Day, it's a Mother's Night If doing it is wrong, I don't wanna be right I'm calling on you cause I can do it myself To me you're like a brother, so be my mother lover Bless us both with the gift of life She brought you in this world,
so I'm a sexer, right?
This is the second best idea that we've ever had The choice can be no other, be my mother lover Happy, Merry Christmas everybody LOL
So I told you guys, I had a...
I had a really really big lonely island phase
So yeah, it was a phase that I had, but don't worry, don't worry guys, don't worry because
because to like, oh sorry, I realize I'm really close right now, but do not worry, I just want you guys to know that, don't worry, I will, don't worry, I'm going to make sure that, I'm going to make sure that things will be fine and that we're going to follow it up with another really good song,
yay, yay, with another, yay guys, come on, aren't you guys feeling the Christmas spirit now, woah, alright here we go, yeah, wait I don't want the Frank Sinatra version, alright here we go, woah okay Michael Bubl version, alright, right after Mother Lover,
by the way, that's Mother Lover from Lonely Island, but right after that, we're going to go, let's go, just, let's go, just to follow the Christmas spirit right after, you better watch out, you better not cry, you better not pout, I'm telling you why,
Santa Claus is coming to town, woah, he's making a list, checking it twice, he's going to find out who's naughty or nice, woah he saw what you did to his mom, Santa Claus is coming to town, he sees you when you're sleeping, and he knows when you're awake,
he knows if you've been bad or good, so be good, for goodness sake, you better watch out, you better not cry, you better not pout, I'm telling you why, Santa Claus is coming to town, oh yes, let's go, yes, he saw what you did last night, woah, that's,
whose mom is that, sir?
oh man, you've been a naughty boy, oh my god, woah, you're best friends too, damn, gotta do it for your homies, right?
I see you when you're sleeping, and he knows when you're awake, he knows if you've been bad or good, so be good, for goodness sake, yeah, hide your moms!
You better watch out.
You better not cry.
You better not pout.
I'm telling you why.
Santa Claus is coming to town.
You better watch out.
You better not cry.
You better not pout.
I'm telling you why.
Santa Claus is coming.
I mean the big fat man with the long white beard.
He's coming to town.
Whoa.
Oh lord, he's coming.
Thanks, Doki.
That's what the lyrics were!
I was reading the lyrics!
Isn't that great?
Isn't that great, Jaegun?
You got the...
Like, right after Mother Lover, we have something like really wholesome to sing right after.
Santa knows what art you watch on Twitter.
Mr. Tooth, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh lord, he's coming.
He knows.
He knows what you've been doing.
Whoa.
Wait, I wonder...
Oh, I don't think they have that.
I was gonna say.
Alright, let me see if they have this song.
Oh my god, I'd be so happy if they do.
Oh, they don't.
Never mind.
Okay, I'll do this song.
This is a really sad song, guys.
I just need you to know that.
This is a really sad song.
It's very sad.
And we'll have the lead singing on the background too.
I thought I had everybody on my side But when I went and blew it all sky high And now she won't even spare a passing glance All just because I ripped my pants Big Larry came around just to put him down Spongebob turned into a clown But no girl ever wants to dance With a fool who went and ripped his pants I know I shouldn't mope around,
I shouldn't kiss But the pain feels so much worse Cause winding up with no one is a lot less fun Than a burn from the sun or sands in your buns
Now I learned a lesson I won't soon forget So listen and you won't regret Be true to yourself, don't miss your chance And you won't end up like the fool Who ripped his pants So true, oh so sad Don't be like him Don't be like him Alright,
that went to autoplay So true, so true Lessons I learned Don't be like him who ripped his pants So sad, so very sad Okay, what if like, oh my god That would be so fucked up if I do this song Okay guys, oh my god Guys, sorry, I'm gonna Did I lose viewers for the songs I've been singing?
Oh my god, my viewership went up Okay, okay, guys Alright, so this next song This next song that I would like to sing It would absolutely I would not be surprised If like, people left after this song Because it is
I would not, I would not be surprised If people, if people leave Okay
This is like I don't know if I can sing this But like, I don't know I've never sang this song before But I've listened to it But this is one of the songs that Mint rejected for the concert
So I'm gonna sing it for my Christmas carols
Seven years Fuck you Things have changed a lot since he left town I gotta send a message of who's really in charge of things now Welcome home I'm gonna make you wish that you'd stay gone Say hello to a new status quo Everyone knows that there's a brand new dawn Turn the TV on...
Camera speeds... rolling in 3, 2...
I'm gonna mess this up.
It's barely audible.
Stop giving that time of day.
Don't listen to a word he's saying.
I hope he had a very nice vacay, but he sure stayed away.
While he hid in radio, we pivot to video.
Now his medium is getting bloody rare.
Hell's been better since he split.
Where's he been?
Who gives a shit?
Yes, I know.
It's been a while since someone with style treated hell to a broadcast.
Singers rejoice instead of a cloud-chasing mediocre video podcast.
This is so fast.
I can't.
Now I got lost.
Is Vox as strong as he proposed or is it based on his support?
He'd be powerless without the other Vs.
And here's the sugar on the cream.
He asked me to join his team.
I said no and now he's pissy.
That's the tea.
I'll show you suffering.
I have to do two rolls.
I'll destroy you!
Alright, now we go here.
How did this get rejected?
You know why.
Let's begin.
I'm gonna make you wish that I'd stayed gone.
Tune on in.
Your status quo will know it's race is run.
All this will be fun.
And
you know why.
You know why it got rejected.
You know exactly why.
I was not allowed to sing that song.
It was sadly not a song that I was allowed to sing.
No, no because I already shitposted too much.
Thank you, thank you.
I already shitposted way too much so I wasn't allowed to include that in my setlist.
Anyway, no because it requires two people.
That is like a duet.
It's a duet so it requires two people to sing that song.
And the second person did not want to sing that song.
So it got rejected.
I feel generous right now and I'm willing to take your song request right now.
Okay.
We'll sing that later.
I like how people were like, this chord is not on KeraFun.
It's not on KeraFun guys.
So is meow meow.
I actually, there's no karaoke version.
I don't know if there is.
Jack Sparrow.
Who's going to be my Michael?
Okay, we'll do Jack Sparrow.
We're just going to be on my Loading the Island era.
We're going to be on my Michael Bolton era.
Alright.
Here we go.
Alright, let's lay it down.
It's...
Let me stop right for this.
Here we go.
Yeah.
What?
Yeah, that's kind of weird, but we're back in the club.
Buying out the bar so the groupie show is love.
Motherfucking Iceman, I'm the top gunna.
Heater on blast, I'm the number one stunna.
Watch it girls, cause I ain't your Mr. No.
More like the meet ya, take ya home and fuck ya twice guy.
All dressed up with nowhere to run.
I know I make you feel crazy when I was born.
No.
Yeah, Jack Sparrow.
Put your hands in the air and say hell yeah.
Come on.
What?
No.
From to the back saying we count stats.
Come on.
Nope.
My father, we're really gonna need you to focus up.
Wait.
Not better.
Come on.
Oh God.
Close enough.
Tony Montana!
This whole town's a pussy.
Just waiting to get fucked.
Alright.
Turns out Michael Bolton is a major cinephile.
Alright, I'm done with my...
Sorry, I'm finished with my Lonely Island era.
I'm done with... I swear it's over now.
Now we go back to the... Sorry, sir.
I'm done with my Lonely Island era, sir.
I hope you've been liking this freestyle.
That is wholeheartedly tailored towards you.
Thank you so much for opening this door for me.
So I can sing you all my favorite songs.
And, you know, my Christmas carols, sir.
Thank you for not closing the door on me when I knocked on your door.
You have a lovely home, sir.
You...
You have a very lovely home.
And I'm really...
I'm really happy to be able to sing some Christmas carols for you.
Oh, man.
Alright, alright.
Let me see.
You know, I can take another...
I can take another song request, sir.
What would you like me to sing?
On this special night.
On Christmas.
You know, it's Christmas.
You sang well.
Thank you, sir.
Busking is really hard.
Christmas is the best time to busk as a singer.
John, thank you.
Thank you for the tip.
Thank you.
Don't stop.
Please do it like a boss.
Okay, guys.
No.
Guys, we can't...
We can't keep doing...
Lonely Island songs, guys.
We gotta move on.
Oh, wait.
Let's do the original.
Wow.
We'll do the original hot to go.
Let me get my child over here.
Alright, child.
It's time to sing with me again.
Yeah!
Wait a minute.
There should be more children.
Let's get the mini...
Oh, wait.
Let's not.
More children!
I said, young men, there's no need to feel down.
I said, young men, pick yourself off the ground.
I said, young men, if you're in a new town, there's no need to be unhappy.
Young men, there's a place you can go.
I said, young men, when you're short on your dope, you can stay there.
And I'm sure you will find many ways to have a good time.
It's fun to stay at the YMCA.
Wow!
They have everything for young men to enjoy.
You can hang out with all the boys.
It's fun to stay at the YMCA.
You can get yourself clean.
You can have a good meal.
You can do whatever you feel.
Whoa!
Young men, are you listening to me?
I said, young men, what do you wanna be?
I said, young men, you can make clear your dreams, but you've got to know this one thing.
No man does it all by himself.
I said, young men, put your pride on the shelf and just go there to the YMCA.
I'm sure they can help you today.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
It's fun to stay at the YMCA.
They have everything for young men to enjoy.
You can hang out with all the boys at YMCA.
It's fun to stay at the YMCA.
You can get yourself clean.
You can have a good meal.
You can do whatever you feel.
Young men, I was once in your shoes.
I said, I was down and out with the blues.
I felt no man cared if I were alive.
I felt the whole world was so jive.
That's when someone came up to me and said, young men, take a walk up the street.
There's a place there called the YMCA.
They can start you back on your way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
It's fun to stay at the YMCA.
They have everything for young men to enjoy.
You can hang out with all the boys.
YMCA, yeah!
YMCA.
Young men, there's no need to feel down.
Oh, wait, how does that go?
I beat myself off the ground.
Oh my god, they sang this part.
And I was like, how the fuck does this go?
It's like, young man, young man.
I'm like, what?
Anyway, my little jokey choir.
Carollers right here.
I fumbled the last part.
It's fun to stay at the YMCA.
Young, young, what is this?
How does this go?
Young man, young man, what do you wanna be?
YMCA.
You'll find it at the YMCA.
No man, no man.
Does it all by himself.
Young man, young man, put your pride on the show.
I had to listen to him.
This just goes to the YMCA.
I had to look at how he sang that part.
I've never heard the ending of YMCA before.
Young man, young man, we all just know YMCA.
Sorry, I didn't know what the ending of YMCA sounded like until now.
That was the first time I've ever heard the ending of YMCA.
All right, that's gonna appear real quick because I need to right click real fast.
I should have.
All right, here we go.
This is my little band of children carollers.
Wait, whoops, not that.
Whoops, not that.
Sorry.
This, there we go.
I moved the wrong thing.
All right, there we go.
My other band of carollers right here.
There we go.
My little...
Sorry, I did control Z, so you saw so many things popped up from that.
Let me make sure they all are resized as much as I'd like.
All right, boop, there we go.
All right, look at that.
My little band of carollers.
My children, that I need to feed.
Yeah, my kids.
All right, there you go.
I didn't want to be too close.
I felt like that was a little awkward being like way too close to you guys.
All right.
What other song?
What other song should we do?
What other songs would you guys like?
Oh wait, there was one.
I was thinking one song that I really want.
Oh wait, all right, guys.
I'll do a favorite of mine.
I'm not very good at this, but like...
Oh my gosh, sorry.
Sorry, wrong child.
All right, children, move.
Daddy's gonna sing now.
Daddy's gonna do some songs that she wants to sing.
All right.
We'll do this and then Feliz Navidad.
And then I'm gonna come into your house.
You're gonna invite me into your house.
All right, after that.
Yeah!
It's one of my favorites.
It's not Christmas, but I like singing this song.
Extravagant, the moon on the Seine, the Seine, the Seine.
Everything is not easy, lost on the Seine, the Seine, the Seine.
I don't know, don't know, don't know why.
Together like this, the Seine and me.
I love this song.
Mr. Lucille, when you are on the Seine, the Seine, the Seine.
Extravagant, when we are on the Seine, the Seine, the Seine.
I don't know, don't know, don't know why.
Together like this, the Seine and me.
It's the bridge of the Seine, my little Lucille, in the middle of the Seine.
It's so beautiful, it's so beautiful.
I breathe it, the waves are pushing on this bridge.
Together like this, the Seine and me.
That's one of my favorite songs.
I really wanted to sing it because it was my favorite song.
I hope you let me, I'm glad you let me.
I can't believe you stood here for two hours listening to this caroler sing.
Like, don't you have a Christmas party to go to?
But it's alright, you know?
I'm technically free entertainment.
So like, maybe your Christmas party was just not it.
But don't worry, that's why I'm here.
Oh my god, sorry, sorry.
And I also left you Frosty the Snowman here too.
So like, everything is great.
But I hope you've been having a good time listening to this good old caroler sing for you.
Trying to make ends meet here down here in the...
I'm trying to make ends meet, you know?
For her family and her dog.
Merry Christmas!
You know what?
I'll give you one last Christmas song.
Before you invite me in.
Invite me into your home.
Alright.
Alright, as promised.
Yeah!
But...
I already missed the entrance.
That's when you know it's live.
Wait, this is the Spanish version.
There should be an English version.
I wanna wish you a merry Christmas.
I wanna wish you a merry Christmas from the bottom of my heart.
I don't know how to sing in Spanish.
Merry Christmas from the bottom of my heart.
How do you pronounce it?
Feliz Navidad.
Feliz Navidad, prospero, something, felicidad.
Apparently I'm not supposed to say that.
No.
Feliz Navidad.
Feliz Navidad, ao.
Okay.
Feliz Navidad, prospero, ao, y felicidad.
I did it!
I wanna wish you a merry Christmas.
Spanish 101 here.
But I wanna wish you a merry Christmas.
I wanna wish you a merry Christmas from the bottom of my heart.
I'm learning today.
Wish you a merry Christmas.
Yeah!
I wanna wish you a merry Christmas.
I wanna wish you a merry Christmas from the bottom of my heart.
Feliz Navidad.
Whoa!
Yeah!
Feliz Navidad, prospero, ao, y felicidad.
Feliz Navidad.
Whoa!
Merry Christmas!
Feliz Navidad.
Yippee!
Yeah!
Feliz Navidad, prospero, ao, y felicidad.
I'm doing it!
I wanna wish you a merry Christmas.
Yeah!
Whoo!
I wanna wish you a merry Christmas.
From the bottom of my heart.
Whoo!
I wanna wish you a merry Christmas.
I wanna wish you a merry Christmas from the bottom of my heart.
Feliz Navidad.
Yippee!
Whoa!
Feliz Navidad, prospero, ao, y felicidad.
Yeah!
You know what?
I feel very, like, festive.
I'll do, like, two more songs.
I feel incredibly festive right now.
The more I sing, the more festive I'm starting.
I'm starting to feel it, guys.
I'm just starting to feel the festivities here.
So I'm gonna do...
I can do, like, two more songs.
I have two more songs in me.
It's hitting.
Yeah, it's hitting right now.
All right.
I'm on a festive streak.
Exactly.
Wait, let me see.
Wait, maybe I could do...
I'm trying to think of, like...
I'm in the zone.
Yeah, but now I gotta think of a song quick or I'll get out of the zone.
I gotta quickly find another song or this zone is gonna be gone.
Feeling the vibes right now.
Yeah, I'm feeling it.
I'm fucking feeling it right now.
Okay, let me see.
Let's see.
I'm trying to see what are some good songs.
Where are some good songs?
Something Christmas-y, guys.
Something Christmas-y.
I need more Christmas songs that I can just pull up.
All right, let's see.
Deck the halls with boughs of holly, Fa la la la, la la la la.
Wait, is there, like...
Wait a minute.
Is there...
Wait, what's that song called?
Okay, I wanna know if they actually have this song.
There's this song, I'm, like, wondering if they actually have it.
Let's see.
I'm trying to see if they have it.
Guys, I'm sorry.
This is...
Sorry, I'm sorry.
I'm looking through my...
I'm looking through my Spotify boombox right now.
Wait, this is actually...
Wait, I'm wondering if this is right.
All right.
I don't know if I can actually sing this, but we can listen to it.
We can listen to this.
Right, let's go.
My my my my...
Mamon nana na na na na.
Banana!
Na na na na na na na na nana bada bada bada.
Banana.
Banana!
I'm so locked in.
This is Lucy from the Muppets.
I'm speaking the word of God.
You are...
This is the sentence.
It's called...
Muna Muna from the Muppets.
Oh my God, you don't know this song?
Oh my God, Zoomers don't know.
You guys don't know.
Fucking peak there.
It's actual peak.
It's actual peak from the Muppets.
It's a classic.
It's actually a peak song right there.
3k just watched me win.
3k people are like, what the fuck is wrong with me?
Super, thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
Merry Christmas, Turkey.
Thanks for all that you've done this year from the charity stream and the Phantom Thief concert.
I was able to make a bunch of new friends and do things I've never done before.
That and get destroyed as a bandage.
Thank you, thank you.
The magenta super.
I like how I used up my one song to be like...
I like how one guy actually joined my membership after that.
They're like, oh my God, I get her now.
Thank you, Big Boss.
Welcome to the tomato frap.
He's like, oh my God, I actually get it now.
Blackfire, thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
PDD, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, man.
Now, please leave my home.
Wait, I have one more song.
Oh my God.
Dorian, I have one more song for you.
Stop.
Don't close the door.
I just have one more song.
To sing for you.
It's gonna be this one.
Wait, okay, before I sing this, I need a...
Okay, let me know if I sound...
Okay.
Christmas time, Christmas time is here.
Time for toys and time for chill.
We've been back for weeks and months.
Merry Christmas, Merry Christmas.
We are playing the loom, the loom.
We are one, a whole, a whole.
We can hardly stand away.
This Christmas don't delay.
Yay!
Oh my God.
I lowered it a bit.
Don't close the door.
You have to let it out.
Okay fellas, get ready.
That was very good.
Very good, Theodore.
Alvin, you were a little flat.
Watch it.
Me flat?
Alvin!
We are playing the loom, the loom.
We are one, a whole, a whole.
We can hardly stand away.
This Christmas don't delay.
Yay!
What do you mean overdo it?
Oh, I'm singing again.
Why can't we sing it again?
Well, wasn't that a great song to end it on, guys?
Guys, guys, wasn't that a great song?
Guys, wasn't that a great song to end it on?
Oh my God, what a...
My ears are still...
This is how dad ears joke you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Most Oshies sing popular anime songs.
My Oshie sings Alvin and the Chipmunks.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look, I know what peak is.
I know, I know what peak is.
Alright, you know what?
No, no, no.
Alright, no, no, no, no.
You know what?
No, I'm giving you guys two more encores.
I'm giving you guys two more encores right here.
Alright.
Okay, this test if I get...
If this VOD gets like censored or not.
This one is the true test.
I want to be the best there ever was.
To beat all the rest.
Yes, that's my cause.
Electro, Diglett, Nidoran, Mankey.
Venusaur, Ratsap, Pharaoh, Pidgey.
Seaking, Jolteon, Dragonite, Ghastly.
Ponyta, Vaporeon, Poliwrath, Butterfree.
Catch him, catch him, gotta catch them all.
Pokmon!
I'll chase across the land.
Look far and wide.
Release from my hand.
The power that's inside.
Venomoth, Poliwag, Nidorina, Dullduck.
Abyssaur, Grimer, Victory, Batmultress.
Snare King, Farfetch'd, Obra, Jigglypuff.
Kingler, Raihan, Clefable, Billytube.
Catch him, catch him, catch him all.
Gotta catch him all.
Pokmon!
Zubat, Primate, Meowth, Onix.
Geodude, Rapidash, Magneton, Snorlax.
Gengar, Tangela, Goldeen, Sparrow.
Weezing, Sealed, Gyarados, Slowbro.
Gotta catch him all, gotta catch him all, yeah!
Gotta catch him all.
Pokmon!
Kabuto, Persian, Paras, Thirsty, Raticate, Magnemite, Caterpillar.
Oh god!
Herpes, Sandshrew, Bulbasaur, Charmander, Golem, Pikachu.
At least one hundred fifty or more to see.
To be a Pokmon master is my destiny.
Alakazam, Dojo, V-Hawk, Macho, Kangaskhan, Hypno, Electrobust, Flare, Blastoise, Poliwhirl, Oddish, Drowzee, Raichu, Litterqueen, Bellsprout, Starmie.
Woah!
We're at the halfway point!
Doing great so far!
We... oh yeah!
That's a lot of Pokmons.
Metapod, Marowak, Kakuno, Killer Fairy, Dojo, Seadra, Vileplume, Krabby, Lickitung, Tauros, Weedle, Nidoran, Mudchop, Shellder, Porygon, Hippochat, gotta catch him all, gotta catch him all, yeah!
Gotta catch him all, gotta catch him all, yeah!
Articuno, Jynx, Nidorina, Beedrill, Haunter, Squirtle, Chansey, Pokemon, Parasite, Exeggcute, Milk, Dewgong, Vegetto, Zephyrus, Vulpix, Rhydon.
Oh my god.
There's 150 or more to see.
To be a Pokmon master is my destiny!
Charizard, Mudchant, Pinstripe, Koffing, Dugtrio, Golbat, Staryu, Magikarp, Ninetales, Inkant, Magiharp, Cypher, Tentacool, Dragon, and Magmar!
Woah!
24 more to go!
Sunflash, Himmelme, Tiduck, Arcanine, Eevee, Exeggcute, Cupido, Zapdos, Dratini, Growlithe, Mr. Mime, Koopa, Graveler, Voltorb, Gloom!
Gotta catch them all, gotta catch them all, yeah!
Gotta catch them all, gotta catch them all, Pokmon!
Chameleon, Wartortle, Mewtwo, Junkrat, Ardactle, Omanyar, Slowpoke, Pidgeot, Arbok, that's all folks!
Oh my gosh.
I just started screaming.
Gotta catch them all, Pokmon!
Okay, if Nintendo strikes me down, I know why.
Because through all 1,164 of them, but they can't put a magenta soup on me.
Thank you, thank you.
It's not easy.
Oh my god.
Okay, I actually, this is like the third time I've ever listened to this song, by the way.
I didn't have PokRap.
I think I stopped, I didn't ever see the opening of the PokRap when I was growing up.
I only saw the original intro.
So I was just like, so the only time I've ever seen PokRap was on YouTube.
And I was just like, and I don't know some of the actual names.
Like, I didn't have to pronounce the actual names.
So like, pronouncing some of the Pokmon, I'm actually pronouncing those names out loud for the very first time.
So I was just like, oh that's a, oh my god, I pronounced that person's name.
Oh, okay, okay.
I'll do one more.
Alright.
For real.
Oh.
Alright.
Everyone always says, Princess Peach, won't you listen to my speech?
I don't have any stars of invincibility.
But you're the brightest star in the sky tonight for me.
I'm your Luigi.
What up, bitch?
I got a one-up, bitch.
What's inside the question box?
It's my dick.
It's a me, a Mario, my Italian, and pastrami.
I'll take you by the peaches and give you the hot salami.
I save you from dragons and evil booze that are spooky.
Must I be a raccoon to get inside you, Tanooki?
I'll mount you like Yoshi and show you things you've never seen.
My mushroom's not mega, if you know what I mean.
So suck it, Mario.
You always do this shit on Like A Girl and then you ruin it by yelling stuff about your dick until they go away.
Okay, someone else be Peach.
I don't wanna be Peach.
You really mean that, Peach?
Oh, princess.
It means so much for me to hear you say that.
The only thing I've ever wanted to tell you is that I'm here to pleasure the ass.
I like to go first, princess, but I always come last.
And you say we'll get together, but I'm jacking off alone.
Koopa Troopa skeletons aren't the only dry bones.
I'm tired of your running around such a fucking hassle.
I go through shit and then you're in another fucking castle.
You gotta think about it while I don't believe the hype.
You'll have a lot of time to think when you're smoking on my warp pipe.
Ahahaha!
Hahaha!
Yeah!
I'm ready to give love a shot.
It's not about how many coins you've got.
I just know I like you a lot.
Yo, slut, check out my yacht!
Let me take you on a magic car ride.
I'll bust all your balloons when I smack your backside.
We'll have some fun.
I'll bring my friends along.
I'll kick that donkey car right in the conky dong.
Come on, peach.
It's time to make your choice.
I'm the only plumber that can make your boobies rejoice.
Green lanky-ass brethren got shit on me.
It's time to live out our story of the princess and the penis.
Hahaha!
So...
I choose...
Toad.
His whole body's shaped like a dick.
Alright, sorry.
I saw somebody said, do Starbomb.
And then, I was like, okay.
Just after Pokemon is final!
Oh my god!
I've never sang this song before.
I've just listened to it.
I've literally just I've literally only just listened to this song.
I've never sang it before.
So I was like, I don't know if I can do the rap part.
But like, everyone says I'm like Aaron Hansen by being bad at video games and just complaining and blaming the game itself instead of reading the instructions.
So I thought like, okay man.
I was just like, you know what?
I just channeled in my Aaron Hansen to... I channeled it in.
Is that Egoraptor?
Oh my god.
That Egoraptor?
Next scene.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
Alright, okay.
Sorry.
This karaoke, this Christmas... I'm sorry, sir.
I'm sorry if your kids are watching and you heard me talking about my penis.
Alright, anyway.
I'm sorry.
I know I sang explicit Luigi's blood during your Christmas session.
I'm not doing your Christmas holiday.
The reason why you're commenting is because you're the VTuber Aaron Hansen embracing.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
I don't know if that's a compliment or an insult.
I don't know.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sing peaches.
Okay, wait.
Is it on carophone?
If it is, I'll sing it.
Alright.
Oh, it is.
Encore number three.
Encore.
Bro, you gotta invite me to the house now.
Come on.
Alright.
This one is for my one and only true love.
Princess Peach.
I've never sang this song, but Peach, you're so cool.
And with my star, we're gonna rule.
Peach, understand.
I'm gonna love you till the very end.
Peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, I love you.
Peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, I love you!
Mario, Luigi and Donkey Kong too A thousand troops of Koopas couldn't keep me from you Princess Peach, at the end of the line I'll make you mine Oh, Peaches, Peaches, Peaches, Peaches, Peaches, Peaches, Peaches, Peaches, Peaches, Peaches, Peaches I love you Oh,
Peaches, Peaches
Bitch!
Guys, this is actually the second time I've ever heard this song
I've never heard this song before until now That's the second time.
That's literally the second time I've heard this song today
Do you think I nailed it for my second time?
Do you think I nailed it, guys?
That was amazing.
Oh my god!
Wait...
Do they have the song from the 2020...
Damn!
Sorry, Encore 4, I have to sing this song I have to sing this song.
I have to.
From such a very good...
I don't know if I can.
I've only listened to... Hey, wake up!
Wake up!
Hey, have you heard about the scuttlebutt?
No, the gossip, the buzz The who said what, who does that?
Yeah, the scuttlebutt I'll fly over that and see an ear to the ground Then I came flying here for you to see and hear what I found Remember the swamp?
Remember the song in the swamp?
When I was like, womp chicka womp womp chicka womp womp What's his name?
The guy with the hair and the shirt?
Yeah, the prince, he's been dropping hits, he wants it You're a human, dress all nice like they're penguins Throw rice for the pigeons, they're trying to blow up the pigeons But those are just urban legends, I know a lot of really fat pigeons Just listen,
Sebastian, got the scuttlebutt You'll be like, what when I drop the scuttlebutt?
Can I have a buttercup?
From when we washed all the clothes to the time two asses froze Get my ass inside
You sound like an alabas, alabas, the kid who sleeps like Toast Oh yes, anything goes, whoever gets our little aerials Magic material, top price in the head, is that what you call it?
The funny with the lips, when they press, I don't have lips, I have a beak See, you're awfully quiet Oh yeah, so what now?
Can you believe the scuttlebutt?
You're welcome for the scuttlebutt Scuttlebutt, scuttlebutt, hey Let's go, let's go, let's go You got it, the gossip, the buzz The who said what, who does that, yeah I told you so Let's go, let's go, let's go We gotta get ready for the big showdown Go ahead and get her out of bed and get ready for the wedding So steady,
so slow down, scuttlebutt
Guys, I love this song Okay, the reason why, I fucking messed that up a lot But like, I love sending these songs to people I hate and love It's so bad, it's such a bad song I couldn't even sing that properly without like cracking up Because it's such a bad song And it's composed by the same guy who did Hamilton,
it's crazy I was like, how do you make that and Hamilton at the same time?
Wait, Toki, why did you send it?
Do you love us or hate us?
Well, I'll never tell you
Have you heard of the scuttle...
Oh my god, I found out that Oh my god, the Lion King move Oh my god, when will they add it?
When will they add the film?
I never had a brother Wait, I'm gonna...
If my VOD gets fucking killed It's from either Disney or Nintendo The Lion King song We're gonna sing...
I'm gonna listen to the song right now with all of you Alright, let's listen to this today I'm willing to risk this VOD, Merry Christmas Guys, this is a new song from the new movie Mufasa I'm willing to risk it all Just for this song
Okay, wait, I'm skipping to the good part I'm skipping to the good part Here we go Okay, here we go I've always wanted a brother I've always wanted a brother I've always wanted a brother Like you I've always wanted a brother I've always wanted a brother I've always wanted a brother Just like you
What the fuck?
I just wanted to sing that part I've always wanted a brother
I've always wanted a brother I've always wanted a brother I've always wanted a brother It's so fucking funny I love it I don't know, I keep loading the lyrics.
I've always, I don't know, apparently the newest Disney songs fucking suck.
I 100% they're terrible.
Actually, literally that's the only part I like because it's so fucking stupid.
Apparently the new, what was it?
What was the sequel they made?
Oh, yeah, Moana 2 was fucking terrible.
The song, apparently the songs for Moana 2 were really, really bad.
Like all the most recent Disney musicals and stuff like that are really bad.
Like, I can't believe it.
Sad.
Good sound writing is when you say the same thing three times in a row.
Bravo, Lin-Manuel Miranda.
Actual showdown.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Have you heard the scuttlebutt?
Well, uh, stick a butter.
Thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you.
Thank you, but a scuttlebutt.
Have you heard of the scuttlebutt?
Wow, the scuttlebutt.
All right, let's see what I can find.
Let's see.
This is...
Do they have this one?
Okay, wait.
Or maybe this one?
Oh my god, I'm looking up some really cursed songs right now.
And see if they have it.
Hey Digimon, hey Digimon.
They don't have Digimon, but they have Butterfly, but we know that's not what we're here for.
What can I say except you're welcome.
Um...
Let's see, stick a butter.
Anyway, did I already say thank you to akasupa to stick a butter?
Thank you again if I didn't.
Thank you.
All right, I'll do one more encore.
I'll do... Sorry, I'm just...
It's been a while, Kiri.
This has been a two hour and 30 minute Kiri.
Okay, I was having way too much fun.
Just shitposting my karaoke.
After Christmas caroling, I was like I can sing anything, but my vibe might disappear, but I can...
I'm definitely not monetized.
That's for sure, but like I can sing anything.
I just I like opened my eyes about it.
Let's see.
I'm checking if there's anything I want to sing.
Yeah, anything else I want to sing before I get invited into your home.
Let's see.
I think I found it.
You're gonna invite me to your house.
Oh, wait, let's go.
This one.
This is what we're here for.
Wait, actually, no, wait.
Wait, not this one.
I'll do... Wait, do they have this other one?
It'll be funny.
You guys can predict exactly what...
Is this what I think it is?
I don't know, but I'll find out.
Built a tent and say the world is dry.
Chocolate rain.
Zoom the camera out and see the light.
Forecast BB falling yesterday.
Chocolate rain.
Only in the past is what they say.
Raise your neighborhood insurance rate.
Chocolate rain.
Make us happy living in the game.
Made me cross the street the other day.
Chocolate rain.
Made you turn your head the other way.
History quickly crashing through the waves.
Chocolate rain.
Using you to fall back down again.
Dude, that's four minutes to help them mention on the radio.
Chocolate rain.
It's a fear your leaders call control.
Worse than sweating.
Worse than calling names.
Chocolate rain.
Say it publicly and you're in trouble.
You're insane.
Chocolate rain.
No one wants to hear about it now.
I can't.
Finish the song.
You wanted to finish it now.
Okay, all right, here we go.
Wish, wish real hard it goes away somehow.
Chocolate rain.
Make the best of friends begin the fight.
But did they know each other and they're like chocolate rain.
Every February washed away.
Chocolate rain.
Stays behind as colors celebrate.
The same crime has a higher price to pay.
Chocolate rain.
The judge and jury swear is not the face.
History quickly crashing through your veins.
Chocolate rain.
Using you to fall back down again.
Dirty secrets of economy.
Chocolate rain.
Turns that body into GDP.
The bell curve blames the baby's DNA.
Chocolate rain.
But test scores are how much they're worth.
Parents make chocolate rain.
Flipping cars in France the other night.
Chocolate rain.
Cleans the sewer else beneath Mumbai.
Chocolate Mumbai.
Cross the world and back.
It's all the same.
Chocolate rain.
Angels cry and shake their heads in shame.
Lifts the arc of paradise insane.
Chocolate rain.
Which part do you think you're living in?
More than marching, more than passing love.
Chocolate rain.
Remake how we got to where we are.
History quickly crashing through your veins.
Chocolate rain.
Using you to fall back down again.
History quickly crashing through your veins.
Chocolate rain.
Using you to fall back down again.
Oh my god.
I felt like I sang this song for 20 years.
This shit is long.
It doesn't end.
I didn't realize how long this song was until now.
I only listened to the first minute.
I've never listened to the full song.
I didn't realize this song was 5 minutes long.
It's 5 minutes long and it's 2 chords.
It's 5 minutes long of the same melody!
Holy shit, I didn't realize it was like that!
Alright, alright.
Okay, okay, okay.
Last, last, last, last, last, last song before you invite me in.
Right?
You're gonna invite me in, right?
Dragons, right?
You're gonna let me inside, right?
Dragons!
Alright, alright, last song.
The very last song.
I don't know if, like, I hope the volume will be okay for this because, like, I don't know.
Alright.
Alright, I'm gonna fumble this.
I don't remember how to actually sing this song.
Alright.
Someday, we'll have our last conversation and drink our last cup of coffee.
Someday, we might be 80 and think about the different things we used to say.
All the memories of you will just become a ghost of a smile caught in the wind.
Someday, it'll be the last day.
I won't forget how it feels to be loved, to be remembered by someone as special as you.
Someday, I will drink that last cup of coffee with a smile.
Yeah?
Do you forgive me now?
Can I come in?
Can I come in now, guys?
Yeah?
Good, I'm already inside.
Wow!
So, my God!
See, I told you.
Wow, Mr. Rich Guy over here.
Whoa!
Oh, my God!
You live here?
Wow!
Look at this place!
Crazy!
I can't believe you live here.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's get it, Doki.
I'm a doge in here, too.
Damn!
I can't believe you live in this place like this.
Whose house is that?
That's your house.
What do you mean?
Maddie, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Dragoon Red super chat.
Merry Christmas, Doki.
It's been an amazing year.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Oh, my God!
Thank you for all the Akasupa!
Thank you for the super chat that you can't make me feel sad after the past 30 minutes.
I think I like the last three of the other songs are like absolute shitposts.
And I'm like, now it's time for you to be sad.
Not sad, but now it's time for you to cry.
That's right.
Let's get some Christmas music in the background, too.
Let's see, royalty-free Christmas songs.
What the f- Okay.
Oh, okay.
Sorry, that's Jacksfilms.
I was like, royalty-free Christmas songs?
And I realized that's from Jacksfilms.
And I was like, what the?
It, like, scared me.
I was like, what the fuck was that?
Like, Jacksfilms.
Yeah, I got scared, too, guys.
I got scared.
It was- It's literally- I looked up royalty-free Christmas songs, and it was the first thing.
Like, it was literally the first result.
Oh, my God.
Thank you all for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you, everyone.
I really appreciate it.
Guys, I'm gonna take off my fucking nose.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna take it off.
Alright, and then...
Thank you, everybody.
I had a lot of fun.
So many Red Supas.
Merry Christmas.
I need to get drunk.
Thank you for the- Thank you for the Akasupa.
Parbo, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, everybody.
Oh, there's so many- Oh, my God.
Sorry, I'm zooming in and out because I'm fucking- Oh, my God.
It's so emotional.
Wow.
Oh, my God.
I really appreciate it, everyone.
Hope you guys had a lot of fun.
I'm- Honestly, I had something else planned for the holidays, for Christmas.
But, obviously, it didn't come through.
But, like, I'm so very happy to be able to still spend Christmas with you guys.
Spend the special holidays with all of you.
It really was- It was really a great time.
I'm so happy to be able to spend it with my Dragoons, since I don't have any- I won't have it any other way.
And I hope you guys had a great time spending your holidays with me.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, this isn't really a Christmas present, but I really want to show you guys this.
But...
My- The Dragoons reference sheet is finally officially done!
Done!
So, I'll show you what it looks like.
Whoa, okay, here we go.
Look!
That's you guys!
The official reference sheet is finally finished!
I have a few edits and everything to make.
But, like, I just wanted to show you guys this.
Before, like, I do some small little edits and everything.
It's just tech.
It's just layout.
All the illustrations are finalized.
It's just I'm here to fix the layout of everything to make it look prettier.
Like, the overlay and everything.
And the text placement and stuff.
So, yeah!
I think it's- I think this is really- I love how it all came out and everything.
And I love the little lore that we have in there.
I just thought it was incre- I thought it looked really cute!
I thought everything looks amazing and really cute.
And everything.
But, I'm super happy to be here for another year.
I cannot- I'll be more sentimental on our New Year countdown chat.
But don't worry.
We'll be a lot more sentimental during the New Year countdown.
Where we look through, you know, all the stuff that happened this year.
But for now, let's think about the holiday cheer.
And spending time together, Dragons.
Noriko!
They gave me the five gifted chips!
Thank you, thank you!
I'm going to sub because I did a ten hour fucking Twitch stream of Marvel Rivals!
But, yeah!
I hope you guys- We started off Christmas-y and then later on we got very shitpost-y.
I feel like I was- It was all over the place.
Today was- Today's stream was all over the place.
And like, I- Honestly, I was improv-ing.
Like, I was doing everything live.
I was improv-ing like 70% of that.
I was trying to set up- For you guys.
It wasn't great.
Oh, you guys had a great Christmas.
For me, I ordered too much- Before this stream, I ordered way too much food because I was talking to a friend.
I was just like- Because they were like, Merry Christmas!
I was like, Merry Christmas!
And I was ordering food.
And I was like, should I order from two different restaurants?
Because I really want to eat these two specific things.
And then, I accidentally ordered an entire- Um...
Entire chicken.
Like...
I ordered a full chicken.
And if you guys don't know how much that is...
It came in two boxes.
It came- It came in two boxes!
Because they were cutting it!
And I didn't- I thought- I thought I ordered a half order.
But I accidentally ordered an entire chicken.
But the thing is, it wasn't the only thing I ordered.
I also ordered like...
Char siu and...
Uh...
Barbecued duck on rice.
Because I was just like- I was really craving, like, classic Hong Kong food.
So I ordered that.
Plus...
The Hainanese chicken hot pot.
But the chicken was in two boxes!
And then...
From the other restaurant, I really wanted dumplings.
So I was like, I'm gonna order some dumplings too.
So I ordered dumplings.
But it came after.
It came like...
It came like 30 minutes after.
So I was like, well, I'm fucking full now.
And then, not only did I order dumplings from the other restaurant...
I also ordered...
I also ordered, like, some cold noodles.
With spicy cold noodles with sesame sauce on it.
Because I was just like, I'll just have a little bit of everything.
Because I'm- I just- It's Christmas, and I want to set up- I just want to have a nice day.
Because I didn't eat lunch.
I woke up at 4 fucking PM.
Oh my god.
I was like...
I was just like, whoop.
Yes, I have leftovers for the next week, apparently.
Oh my god.
Merry Christmas, everybody.
Merry, merry Christmas.
Yeah, I'm so happy to spend it with all of you guys.
Oh my god, what a year.
What a fucking year.
Oh my gosh.
Oh yeah, I forgot.
I need to show this one thing.
But...
If you're in Hong Kong...
I'm gonna be doing a very special fan meet in Hong Kong.
And I would really mean a lot to see you guys.
Because like...
As- Wait, let me grab the links.
I can- Guys, I'm doing it all live.
There's also exclusive merch too being sold.
But yes.
Hong Kong fan meet.
I would really appreciate seeing all of you guys there.
If you are traveling to Hong Kong, it's gonna be on January 11th.
So yeah.
Purchase your tickets and grab some exclusive merch over there.
I really wanna go- I really miss Hong Kong.
I wanna go back there.
I'm planning on going back there next year.
So like...
I'm super excited because it's been so long since I've been back.
I think it's been like 5 or 6 plus years since I've been back.
Because when COVID happened, I never- It's been a long- Basically, I haven't gone back since COVID.
But I also haven't gone back even before COVID.
But like, ah man.
But yes.
Please purchase.
Sorry, whoop, dad's here.
Sorry, dad's gone again.
He comes in and out because like...
There's a reason why.
But here's dad again.
And he's gonna disappear again soon.
But yes.
My fan meet right here.
Guys.
There's a lot of community posts I need to make.
Maybe I still don't know.
Please.
Come to Hong Kong.
If you've never been to Hong Kong, you should totally come to Hong Kong.
It's great.
It's actually a great place.
Great place.
Honestly, I love the food there.
It's also really nice.
But yes.
If you're not from Hong Kong, you should totally come over too.
I heard there's gonna be like lots of fun stuff there at the fan meet.
But yeah.
I'm super excited.
Please visit.
Buy tickets now.
Good thing.
I almost forgot to show this.
Because I had to show this.
Because they're like, can you please talk about this on stream?
And I was like, I will.
Don't worry.
And I forgot to yesterday.
So I was like, I'm gonna do it now.
I was like, oh my god.
Okay.
I'm gonna remember now.
I'm a professional.
I'm a fucking professional.
Delta, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you for the congratulations on an amazing stream and amazing year.
Just being genuinely amazing.
Merry Christmas Doki Bird.
Merry Christmas Little Dragons.
To an amazing 2025 together.
Yes!
I'm super excited for 2025.
And spending the new year countdown with you guys.
I'm super duper excited for it.
Because I'll be releasing transparent PNGs of the Dragoons.
Because we're going to follow tradition.
And you can submit your own Dragoon Sona to me.
I'll make a tweet about it.
Like, maybe tomorrow or today.
I don't know.
I'm a wild card.
Depending on if I'm fucking gone in the Marvel Rivals minds.
It really depends on if right after the stream, I'm just fucking gone in the Marvel Rivals minds.
So it's a 50-50.
If it's going to be today or tomorrow.
But I will be releasing the transparent PNGs of the Dragoons.
So you can make your own Dragoon Sonas.
So we can do a countdown together.
As always.
As per tradition.
I'm always super happy to just hang out with all of you guys.
And just be there with you guys.
And you guys made this Christmas amazing.
I mean, I always love celebrating it with my fans and my community and everything.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, delay no more.
Thank you.
Thank you for the superchat.
There's so many things going on.
I'm like trying to catch up with everything.
Marvel Rivals could not have released at a worse fucking time.
I'm not gonna lie.
They couldn't have released at a worse time.
Trying to catch up with everything.
Yeah, I hope you guys had a great holiday.
I mean, I have a lot of other stuff planned for 2025.
I mean, I had stuff planned for this year.
That's to be pushed to 2025.
Because I was just so overworked.
There's been so many things going on.
But I'm hoping to chill a little more.
And for the next week or two.
If I get back into the whole grind again.
But yeah, I can't believe we've been streaming for three hours now.
I got like really lost in the script of my Christmas karaoke.
I'm sorry for being an hour late.
Setup took a lot longer than I thought it would.
Because I had a lot of fucking dumb ideas in my head.
And I realized I fucked up.
I forgot the most important thing of the setup.
I still hope you guys enjoyed it and everything.
I think it's because I woke up way too late for setup.
It usually takes me like an hour.
An hour and a half to set up all my scenes for it.
But I hope you guys still...
I hope you guys enjoyed the theme of everything.
Anyway guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
Thank you all for the Akasupa's.
I hope you guys had...
And all the superchats.
And all the subs.
And all the memberships.
I hope you guys had a great, great Christmas.
Spending it time with me.
Also, we're gonna have a new emote.
By the way.
I'll show it to you guys.
You guys might recognize.
I'm asking for a few edits.
Sorry, that's gonna disappear for a sec.
Because I'm starting to save this.
And then he's back.
But I'll show you guys this.
We have a new emote.
Here.
You might recognize what this face is supposed to be.
I really wanted to have this particular face.
The side eye.
So yeah.
That's gonna be a new emote.
I'm just gonna get a few edits made to it.
And then we're gonna have it soon.
Anyway.
Oh yeah.
I mean.
Since it's the holidays.
I can show you guys more stuff before I go.
Wait.
I have so many things to show you guys.
Actually.
Actually, I have a lot of things to show you guys.
Not gonna lie.
I actually have a lot.
It's not.
Let me see.
That's gonna disappear again.
Because I need to save this.
Actually, I have a lot of stuff working in the background.
And I need to answer them.
Because I'm a little late in answering these.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
They've been like on standby on these for so long.
But I had so many million other things going on in the background.
But.
I'm gonna have a.
I'm sorry.
That's just gonna jump in and out.
I'm gonna have a little chibi model.
I got very inspired by.
Mint's chibi skin suit.
And I got very inspired by Mint's chibi skin suit.
It's not the same artist.
But.
That's me.
Wow.
That's mini me.
It's being worked on right now.
Well, to be fair.
It's almost.
It was almost done a month ago.
And then I got really busy.
So I haven't been able to give them notes.
But yeah.
Yeah.
There's gonna be a lot of like toggles and everything.
Anyway.
I just want to show you guys this.
Wow.
I was.
I was wondering if I should keep it a surprise.
But then I might as well show it during.
For Christmas.
As a little gift.
Gift.
Like.
Look.
Look at this.
I'm sorry.
I don't really have a gift.
Gift for you guys.
This year.
There's a lot of things happening in the background though.
So there will be some little gifts for you guys in the future.
For 2025.
But thank you everybody.
I'm gonna call it here.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
Any of you?
Still for me?
Head to bed.
Guys.
You deserve it.
I mean.
For those who watched my 10 hour fucking VOD of Marvel Rivals.
You're way.
You're so strong.
And then right after.
A three hour karaoke.
Oh my god.
You're so strong.
And thank you all for the Akasupas.
All the Akasupas that were sent today.
Thank you so much everybody.
Thank you for your support.
It really really means a lot.
And guys.
Merry Christmas everybody.
I'll see you guys tomorrow.
And also for New Years.
Bye bye everyone.
Bye.